quand on pense à trappes on pense à
nicolas anelka jamel debbouze ou encore
ben omar sy des stars qui ont grandi
dans les quartiers de cette ville
mais ces derniers jours le nom de
trappes nous évoque surtout ça on a
commencé par les juifs
ensuite c'était la communauté portugaise
et maintenant ce sont les musulmans
ordinaires je dirais qu'ils s'en vont et
le maire un prof de philo qui se dit en
danger de mort après avoir tenté de
prendre la défense de samuel pâti dans
les médias ou lors de ses cours samuel
pâtit ce professeur décapité par un
terroriste islamiste en octobre dernier
un professeur d'histoire a donc était
assassiné parce qu'il enseigne à nos
valeurs les plus chers au didier lemaire
trap est devenue une ville tombée aux
mains des islamistes
kraft cette ville de 34 500 habitants
dont 25% vit dans une grande pauvreté
des difficultés qui ne sont pas
seulement sociale puisque en vingt ans
la délinquance à trappes a augmenté de
100%
justement le problème est réel il existe
si dieu le maire crie haut et fort que
trap est devenue une ville dangereuse
des élus et ses collègues prétendent le
contraire pour le professeur cherche à
diviser encore plus alors la ville de
trappes est elle dangereuse
ce soir jean bessière et le maire de
trappes ali rabais se font face donc
avec jambes et ses éditorialistes
président de l'institut à paulhan et
ancienne figure du rassemblement
national
merci d'être là j'ambitionne magnifiques
costumes 3e série rabais maire de
trappes depuis jeu mêlant merci merci
monsieur le maire d'être avec nous et
c'est vrai que là la ville de trappes
est elle vraiment dangereuse alors c'est
vrai qu'on entend plein de choses sur la
ville de trappes
qu'est ce que vous répondez même j'ai vu
que vous aviez réagi à ce professeur qui
avait dit qu'il avait été menacé
qu'est ce que vous dites vous de la
merci de votre invitation ça me permet
de vent beaucoup de téléspectateurs de
rétablir de trois vérités c'est
important et l'objectif
moi je suis maire d'une ville et je
représente 32 mille habitants trente
deux mille habitants qui depuis quatre
jours se font insulter injurié
caricaturé à la transe et qui se sentent
humiliés bien sûr et donc je viens
apporter un peu leur parole ici parce
qu'il m'écrive il m'appelle il m'a
m'interpelle dans la rue ils me disent
on a besoin d'être défendu parce que là
c'est trop dur
d'ailleurs moi comme maire c'est très
dur ce que je vis depuis quelques jours
c'est d'abord d'ailleurs ce qu'on
parlait de menaces de mort de protection
policière
ce sont des menaces des insultes ce
qu'on appelle la fachosphère se
déchaînent depuis quatre jours et c'est
tous les jours vraiment un torrent
d'insultés d'injures racistes
de calomnies de diffamations de la part
d'élus d'ailleurs dans mes femmes
politiques membres du parti a quitté
monsieur messia le rassemblement
national mais donne des noms ou là c'est
pas ce qui manque c'est vos amis en
dénonce j'ai fait une liste est longue
comme le bras et il se porterait plus
emballant ces accusations comme ça donne
alors il faut donc on va le dire est ce
que ma ville est dangereuse dans ma vie
il ya des problèmes mais comme dans
toutes les villes de france et chez moi
y en a un peu plus qu'ailleurs parce que
on est une ville qui est frappé par tous
les maux qui frappent la société
française et qui sont exacerbées chez
nous ya plus de délinquance et plus de
chômage elle plus de pauvreté nature il
ya de la radicalisation
il ya des phénomènes d'embrigadement
sectaire on est un creuset de ce qu'est
la france d'ailleurs dans ce qu'elle a
de meilleur et de pire
d'ailleurs c'est une ville particulière
trappe c'est une petite ville de 32
mille habitants il y en a plein et on
parle aujourd'hui aujourd'hui toute la
france toute la france alors les frappes
mais trappe cyril vous le savez
d'ailleurs cette frappe c'est la ville
qui donne à la france à la fois
jamel debbouze nicolas anelka et plein
d'autres assurent pourtant c'est une
ville anonyme de 32 mille habitants y en
avait plein et c'est une ville aussi où
il ya toutes ces difficultés et où
malheureusement par exemple les dizaines
de jeunes ou de moins jeunes à trappes
sont allés en syrie en irak faire le
jihad et moi je suis confronté à tous
ces défis et je dois ils répondent tous
les jours sur le terrain avec le chef
d'établissement du lycée de la plaine de
loof où enseigne ce prof qui nous a
caricaturé avec les différentes
associations dans ma ville qui font du
sport qui font des actions caritatives
et on est entravée dans notre boulot
quotidien et compris pour lutter contre
la radicalisation justement par des gens
qui hurlent sur les plateaux télé qui
invective qui insulte qui a juré qui
caricature et qui raconte et qui
colporte des mensonges par exemple j'en
cite deux ou trois et franchement je ne
sais pas certains d'entre vous grandit
ont vécu ou on traversait la banlieue
quand on dit de trappes que c'est une
ville où il n'y a pas de coiffure mixte
oui j'ai une grosse tignasse n'ai pas eu
le temps d'aller chez le coiffeur ces
derniers jours il ya ce que disent elles
ce prof de philosophie qui indiquait
qu'il n'y avait plus aucun coiffure
mixte à trappes et bien dans ma ville il
ya quatre coiffure mixte et y en a même
un qui à 50 mètres du lycée où monsieur
le maire didier lemaire enseigne tous
les jours d'accord dans ma ville on m'a
expliqué mme didier lemaire a expliqué
et c'est ça qui est calomnieux pour les
habitants et que les habitants ne
comprennent pas on a expliqué que les
enfants dans les
dans les écoles maternelles j'ai quinze
écoles maternelles ne chante pas parce
que l'islam le leur interdit est-ce
qu'il y en a 1 ici qui imaginent que les
1500 enfants scolarisés dans les écoles
maternelles de trappes s'interdisent de
chanter à cause de leurs les profs les
laissera pas faire les profs et les
oblige rage c'est pas le cas c'est des
enfants de maternelle vous assurerez
chantiers davie chant des oiseaux il se
touche avec ses font des bisous unis
comme dans toutes les villes de france
donc dire ça tenir des propos aussi
caricaturaux c'est se discréditer et
d'ailleurs oui c'est pas lire abbey qui
le dis c'est pas le maire de trappes
c'est pas les habitants de trappes qui
disent cela
c'est aujourd'hui la république et ça
c'est un honneur de la république le
préfet des yvelines s'est exprimé hier
parce qu'un journaliste un peu sérieux
une journaliste a fait une enquête à
vraiment creuser à recouper les
informations ce que racontait cet
enseignant et cette journaliste a
recueilli des témoignages du
renseignement un territoire yal de
l'antiterrorisme du préfet des yvelines
ils s'expriment lui-même pour dire non
ce qui est dit est faux
nous avons une coopération comme il n'y
en a jamais eu à trappes et je le
revendique sur les enjeux de lutte
contre la radicalisation contre
l'islamisme et c'est entre le nouveau
maire de trappes et la préfecture et les
services de lutte anti aujourd'hui on
c'est vrai que trap est sous le feu des
projecteurs
voilà c'est une petite vie vous l'ayez
de 32 mille habitants et tout le monde
en parle c'est venu en fait un exemple
dans le mauvais sens état doit vous gêne
et voilà qu'on parle comme ça de votre
ville et on a envie de savoir voilà ce
qui s'y passe vraiment aujourd'hui
vous étiez en top tweets vraiment tout
le monde parlait que de trappes
alors j'en mets ça quand vous entendez
alliera b le maire de trappes qui dit
que tu rappes est une ville voilà comme
les autres où il se passe aussi bien des
bonnes choses que des mauvaises et que
c'est une ville voilà qu'est ou voilà il
faut essayer de faire il a découvert
plein de gens voilà qui font aujourd'hui
le bonheur de la france qu'est ce que
vous dites à ça ben moi je trouve que le
maire de trappes
et très talentueux il est très
talentueux il va dire une saloperie
derrière parce qu'il a une façon très
élégante et très diplomatique de nier la
réalité c'est quoi la réalité c'est
qu'en réalité tout le monde sait
attrape-moi gens plus le connaîtra parce
qu'il se trouve que le lycée où enseigne
didier le maire j enseigne et moi-même
en l'an 2000 donc ce projet ça j'ai fait
un remplacement et soeurs qui a dit
qu'il avait été menacé
voilà exactement donc je dirais tous les
français savent qu'il y a en france
trappe n'y fait pas exception il y a en
france effectivement des zones non pas
de non droit mais des zones de non
france et trappes en fait partie alors
moi au début parce que le maire j'ai eu
j'ai eu envie de de croire en votre
bonne foi mais quand j'ai vu votre votre
parcours politique vous êtes de gauche
vous avez appartenu au ps et ensuite
vous avez suivi la gauche kebab east de
benoît hamon
vous dites que vous défendez la
république française très bien mais le
problème c'est que le courant politique
auquel vous appartenez a tout fait
depuis 40 ans pour que la république ne
soit plus française en réalité trappe
comme beaucoup d'autres villes en france
est devenue une médina
voilà là comment voulez-vous 40 ans
comment voulez vous comment voulez vous
qu'une médina soit française
comment voulez vous que dans une ville
où on parle l'arabe
on s'habille à l'arabe on vit à l'art à
bon prix en arabe
comment voulez vous qu'on se sente
français leur placement d'une semaine
j'ai vu tout noir j'ai passé une semaine
six mois donc si vous voulez moi je
voilà donc la deuxième chose que je vais
vous dire c'est que vous nous dites
également que voulu te faire depuis que
vous êtes élu maire que vous avez un
gros effort de lutte contre les
phénomènes de radicalisation contre le
communautarisme et déjà donc déjà des
offres d'emploi de ville oui mais donc
déjà voulez vous reconnaissez qu'il ya
c'est qui c'est qui a ces phénomènes
attrape parce que là vous entendre
trappe serait une ville lendemain comme
il
mais ce que je constate un parent c'est
que vous déployer une énergie dévorante
depuis plusieurs jours pour déglinguer
le témoignage de didier lemaire alors
que je vous ai jamais vus sur aucun
plateau venir nous fait nous faire état
de des services que vous avez rendu dans
la lutte contre l'islamisation de la
ville contre la communautarisation etc
voilà je pense que le but en réalité
c'est que il n'y ait pas de trappe qui
se généralise sur le territoire français
voyez donc déjà il faut commencer par
admettre le réel ouvrir les yeux sur le
réel vous pouvez pas casser le
thermomètre
alors que le patient souffre d'un cancer
en stade iv et qui provoque de la fièvre
vous pouvez pas dire je balance le
thermomètre des témoignages et hop
donc la meilleure que la réalité
n'existe plus qu'est ce que vous
répondez à jour mais siens
c'est exactement la raison pour laquelle
j'ai accepté votre invitation serait
bien balancé sans pièce où vous n'êtes
pas des brèches ces caricatures attrape
ont pris en arabe à l'église catholique
de trappes où se réunissent des
centaines de personnes tous les
dimanches matins on doit prier aussi en
arabe pendant que vous y êtes
quelle est la proportion de cas de la
population chrétienne argent sérieux ne
découpe pas la population encore gorille
moi je suis français républicain est
d'accord les gens en face de moi ils
sont français qu'ils soient de
pondichéry de bretagne qu'ils soient
catholiques ou musulmans et je fais pas
une statistique mais qu'est ce que cette
journée était de matériaux moi je vous
aimez les chaînes de vos élucubrations
josé pas interrompue parce que vous avez
le droit d exprimer en démocratie donc
pour mercy ici dans ma ville
on vit vraiment de façon paisible et
apaisée il ya des difficultés qu'on
combat tous les jours mais je vais vous
donner une anecdote qui date d'il ya
quelques heures on m'interpelle dans un
groupe whatsapp où je suis j'organise
quelques associations de solidarité qui
sont raides et j'ai le secours
catholique qui nous écrit pour nous
signaler
je n'ai pas donné de nom mais une
personne en difficulté qui dort à la
ruine dame une femme qui battus et qui
va dormir à la rue ce soir donc les
associations centraide je les envoie
vers le centre communal d'action sociale
et c'est un président d'association
darche désolé pour lui je vais le dire
qui par ailleurs est de confession
musulmane
il est président d'une association de
ce2 caritatives il paye trois nuits
d'hôtels pour la personne agressée par
le secours catholique
il ya notre association
le relais le temps de la mairie après en
chef et on essaye de se débrouiller en
fait sur le terrain non vous vous faites
un homme abracadabrantesque nous sur le
terrain on essaie de s'entraider et de
régler les problèmes
alors là je rencontre la radicalité qui
peut nous mettre en danger tous à
trappes
parce qu'on est en première ligne on est
concerné et puis vous tous qui au delà
d'ailleurs bien sûr le monde entier donc
moi j'ai des gamins dans ma ville qui
ont peur pour leur avenir j'étais hier
matin au lycée de la plaine 2 nov le
lycée concerné je pensais que j'allais
trouver des gamins révolte est énervé
qui attendaient de réglisse et concerts
déversera le professeur qui a dit qu'il
avait été exactement mais j'ai parlé des
élèves
qu'est-ce qui nous est en fait j'ai été
très surpris je le disais tout à l'heure
à lors d'une réunion gisait au lieu
d'avoir des élèves révolté est mobilisé
j'avais en face de moi des gens qui
avaient peur peur pour leur avenir la
première gamine que j'ai croisés elle me
dit moi je suis super inquiète pour mon
bac de philo je vais pas pouvoir finir
le programme et les forces de l'ordre
sera plus là et serra et comment on va
faire pour le bac de philo les autres il
ya un attroupement qui s'est fait
pendant un cours de récréation autour de
moi pour qu'on en discute les autres me
disent mais on est mort on est mort
quand on voudra sur parcours sup avoir
une école d'ingénieur université qu'on
vise et ses acquis et sélective
on n'y arrivera pas parce qu'on sera
stigmatisé parce qu'on vient de trappes
ce qui est déjà la réalité en temps
normal alors moi les gens comme vous et
j'ai rien contre vous je vous connais
même pas sa première fois que je vous
croise dans un plateau j'espère
peut-être la dernière et a mis son plus
beau coup il a mis son roi singe
costumes à 150 balles moi j'ai pas les
moyens excusez moi mais les gens comme
vous mr quand même vivre dans un
fantasme est moins sévère vous moi j'ai
pas de haine pour vous c'est vous et
vous je me savais pourquoi j'ai de la
peine pour vous parce que dans votre
tête et je pense que vous il ya une
forme de sincérité chez vous vous êtes
obsédé par des sujets vous organisez une
forme de guerre civile et vous avez
l'air terrorisé enfin non mais c'est
nous on vit tranquillement et on s'aime
mais même sans le mr à monsieur moi je
prendrais les peurs des français peur de
votre propre image en miroir peut-être
les francs et moi je sais faire ça non
mais vous avez déjà affirmé qu'il avait
déjà psychiatrisés des îlots mais on en
a qui ne l'est pas cicatrisé ceci nous
français fier de l'être
on le revendique on n'a pas peur de
l'être on essaie d'être tranquille même
sentir trahi et monsieur le maire
alors monsieur le maire mais vous en
mettez sur foot ni au juste la paix on
doit quel pays vivez vous est ce que
vous croyez en est ce que vous croyez
qu'en france actuellement dans l'état de
guerre civile larvée dans lequel nous
sommes ou chaque jour des gens se font
poignarder se font agresser et c est ce
que vous croyez que les ca ca a besoin
de gens comme moi pour que ça arrive
c'est pas parce que au maître des mots
et notes emtn sur des mots et mahut x
pour les des fauteurs de guerre au
contraire on est des lanceurs d'alerté
il faut à un moment écarquiller les yeux
sur le réel vous savez très bien qu'en
france vous avez des millions de
personnes qui sont effectivement
administrativement française mais qui
n'ont aucune en allégeant son vis-à-vis
de la france
est ce qu'il appelle une ville dont jos
est la question oui j'aurais terminé
elle a fait une ville dangereuse parce
que c'est une ville qui fait partie
alors je sais qu'en ce moment il ya le
projet de loi qui est discuté sur le
séparatisme sans doute que vous y voyez
un une occasion collatéral pour attaquer
ce projet de loi mais en réalité trappe
fait partie de ces villes qui sont
touchés par la loi voilà et la
république française vous savez elle
s'est construite avec un peuple d'accord
un peuple français avec lee avec
l'immigration massive ces quarante
dernières années
certaines zones ont changé deux peuples
trappe aujourd'hui c'est pas trappe d'il
ya cent ans ou 70 ans maintenant la
trappe voilà donc si vous voulez le
problème sa carrière du moment à partir
du moment attendait alors laissez moi
finir en 2008 et à partir du moment où
le peuple changent mais la république ne
peut plus être qualifié de française ça
reste une république mais elle n'est
plus française terminé parce qu'on voit
ce que vous croyez que les gens qui
habitent à trappes ont tous choisi
souvent ils sont là parce qu'on leur a
des idées on leur a désigné
l'appartement
oui la sueur hlm dans lequel il devait
vivre bien sûr si aujourd'hui attrape
les couleurs vous conviennent pas
c'est parce que la république a organisé
les ghettos dans notre pays n'ont que
faire des projets de loi qu'ils feront
je veux qu'on casse les ghettos et qu'on
organise le mix c'est pas vrai ça veut
dire que vous êtes amis qui vivent entre
millionnaires dans des quartiers ghettos
de riches nova gt2 se mélanger non
attrapons maintenant hollande et les
mêmes quartiers les mêmes quartiers
accueillait et les mêmes quartiers
accueillez il ya 50 ou 60 ans la classe
populaire ouvrière française
il n'y en a jamais eu de problème
d'argent j'ai dû rattraper c'est parce
qu'il ya eu
un changement de population que l'
architecture s'est dégradée et non pas
parce qu'il ya larchitecture kylie a
effectivement les phénomènes de
population de criminogènes notre qui me
fait mal le plus mal moi je viens des
quartiers le truc qui me fait le plus
mal c'est cette évasion des quartiers
qui a fait devenir des ghettos pourquoi
parce que faut pas le nier il ya eu des
bordels dans le quartier il ya nommé qui
font de la bécane à 3 heures du matin il
ya de la délinquance mais voilà quand tu
peux aller à la banque et demande et
après tu te barres anelka s'est barré
omar s'est barré javed seebach et tout
le monde s'est barré ce qu'il faut
maintenant c'est remettre de l'ordre
dans les cités pour que les gens restent
dans leurs cités qu'ils aiment les gens
ils veulent juste aller au boulot
calmement
ils veulent pas avoir des feux de
poubelles à une heure du matin elles ne
veulent pas te réveiller par les
pompiers
ils veulent pas casser les plans tant
que ça mais voilà c'est comme ça j'ai
pas revendre joue pas mal 40 ans de
gauche moi j'ai parlé de ça je veux
juste que l'ordre revienne dans les
cités parce que je veux que les gens
aiment leur cité je veux que sur les
photos de classe il y ait tout genre de
personne tout genre de faire ça des
populations et le vivre ensemble et ça
c'est ce qui me fait le plus mal
si un jour je m'engage en politique
syrie je te jure que c'est vrai